I say listen you get to roll out be fat
yeah shape be broke be unimportant with
no girlfriend and instead of the world
thinking you're a loser you get to say
I'm not a loser I'm depressed it's a
shield yeah yeah and I say that's why
you don't want to lose your Shield
because now you have accountability now
you have performance it's a cop out [ __ ]
it off I don't give a [ __ ] if it's real
or not we're not about that we're
talking about success here get rid of
your excuses stop defending the thing
that's ruined your life and get to work
and every time anyone has ever listened
to me in history Ever every single one
of them's transform their lives and
message me positive messages afterwards
every single time that's why I'm out I'm
anti-antidepressant because that pill
ain't gonna Fix You the Way becoming the
man you wish you were is gonna fix you
it's it's crazy and then they're going
to take one little sound bite Tate
doesn't care about men's mental health
he thinks depressed people is some
[ __ ] and they're gonna apply it to
me I really do believe and I State this
almost with the degree of
achievement I'm the most misunderstood
man on the planet